nationwide the number of coronavirus
cases passed the 9 millionth mark today
cases are surging in illinois where
nearly 7 000 new infections were
reported friday
today more than 3 000 people are
hospitalized
some hospitals in michigan say they are
concerned that they're running out of
bed space
south dakota is seeing more than 13
thousand active cases
a new single day record denise and
kirsten we've had nearly a million cases
in this country just in the past two
weeks
and we're not alone because across the
pond france is now the latest country to
enforce a total
lockdown to try and stop the virus paris
saw
huge traffic jams overnight as all these
residents were just trying to get out of
town before the mandate
police were clashing there with
protesters who hit the streets rejecting
the new government order
germany also heading into a lockdown as
it struggles to bring this latest wave
of coronavirus under control
looking at video here britain's
government we meanwhile is
under growing pressure to close down
that nation
as cases there also continue to spike we
are seeing a surge tied to these coveted
infections nevada reporting look at this
number more than 100
i should say more than 1 000 new cases
this is the third time this week we've
seen a number this high
just over 1200 since yesterday clark
county reporting 890 new cases and seven
deaths
the southern nevada health district says
the increase is expected with the trend
of
high community transmission and as
people continue to get tested
the recovery rate though fairly robust
at 90 percent
now also something to note clark county
saw more than 11
000 tests in just the last 24 hours